new york raises income taxes on super
wealthy raising concerns among
corporations
a morning bruce story last week
lawmakers passed a budget that raised
the personal income tax on individuals
for over a million dollars and
introduces two new brackets of those
making
more than 5 million and 25 million can
you imagine you have a tax bracket for
people making over 25 million dollars a
year
the changes mean that the wealthiest new
york city residents will face the
highest combined local and state
personal income rate in the country
surpassing california new york
officially passed california interesting
so 250 business executives have sent a
letter to state lawmakers arguing that
the higher taxes would jeopardize new
york's recovery from the economic crisis
inflicted by covet 19
by sending high net worth people fleeing
meanwhile just three hours south of the
jetblue flight miami twitter
in chief mayor suarez is welcome in new
york's wealthy with a promise of zero
state income taxes and carbon
reservation which makes new york city
leaders including mayoral candidates
andrew yang and ray mcguire anxious
that that tax hike could lead to a 1970s
corporate exodus when the city lost half
of its fortune 500 companies
and then keep going to the next story
very interesting new york city
wealthiest look to exit
as a state readies hefty tax increase
that's a cnbs story
it's different stories new york's top
business leaders are gearing up for
potential mass exit is
as common state lawmakers prepare to
raise their taxes with the state budget
set to increase the personal income tax
on the wealthiest new yorkers okay we
covered that wealthy business leaders
who have historically resisted moving at
least some of their resources to florida
or other less less tax state uh
explained that they are now
seriously considering as working from
homes
becomes the norm allowing more
flexibility florida does not have
a personal okay so similar story two
different articles
by the way you know who just moved to
florida palm beach and bought a 83
million out of home
yeah just about an 83 million dollar
home and then tearing it down
and donald trump jr and kimberly
got a place in jupiter for 9.6 million
they sold their house i think in
uh connecticut are they married or just
dating they're not
i i i wouldn't know i wouldn't know
they're not i think they're i think
they're just dating
seriously dating though but go ahead
what do you think about new york any
different opinions
i mean we've been following this story
this is not a new story i just love
shout out to my guy mayor francis suarez
we hung out with him the other day
we were at the event this was literally
one week ago i believe
um and i just love how all roads leave
to florida
lead to florida and specifically miami i
love how he has now taken the new
moniker the tweeter in chief francis
suarez
so how can i help come on down to
florida the weather's fine
by the way some people still don't know
that valuetainment is in florida i get
that when do you go
well today video went out saying why i
moved to florida i just went out
finally this morning yeah well about
time yeah finally so
we're in florida and it's just uh come
on down new york
you know the thing that just annoys me
is just the the level of
unsophistication and uncreativity that
these politicians have in these states i
mean you got to make a
a conscious decision i'm going to live
in new york and i'm going to live in
california i'm just going to have to
deal with it right
there's better alternatives and you look
at a state like florida and texas that
has no state income tax and they're
thriving
they are taxing less and it's working
and these bozos just think we'll just
keep adding taxes
and the lowest hanging fruit is the rich
people it's the corporations it's people
making 25 million or more so that's the
easy
target you go against the extra you know
few billion that you pump into the
general economy and it doesn't do
anything
because the other story attached to this
is how they're giving away thirteen
thousand dollars to
undocumented immigrants or something in
new york as well which is
staggering and um do you have that story
in here because that's right i'd like to
go
right above that story what which page
is it on same page there you just read
the
same okay there it is page six okay
let's go into that as well because they
all go together 2.1 billion dollars
for undocumented workers signals new
york's progressive shift this is a new
york times story which is
the most progressive newspaper out there
saying progressive shift after sweeping
move by lawmakers this week new york
will now offer one-time payments of up
to fifteen thousand six hundred dollars
to undocumented immigrants who lost work
during the pandemic
the effort a 2.1 billion dollar fund in
the state budget is by far the biggest
of its kind in the country and a sign
that the states shift towards
policies championed by progressive
democrats such as
aoc in the state of new york republicans
instantly criticize the measure
as out of touch at a time when many
other new yorkers were still struggling
while
some democrats from swings districts
upstate and on long island said
privately
that a publicly funded rescue program
for people are not in the country
legally would be wielded
as a uh as a
uh against cudgel against them and
future elections
new york's fund dwarfs a similar relief
program enacted in california where
officials
set up a 75 million cash assistant
program last year and gave undocumented
immigrants a 500
one-time payment on a first-come
first-served basis this is
fifteen thousand six hundred dollars
yeah they probably won't tax them either
if you're
okay look adam do you support this no
hell no mine is ridiculous
that's unfair look this is undocumented
immigrants these aren't
you know so if you're gonna if you're
gonna give a 500 payment to
you know somebody or stimulus to your
fellow americans cool i get it
fifteen thousand freaking dollars to
undocumented don't pay attention how
does that even
how is that even a good idea i would
love to get the other end of the
spectrum
it's unfair they lost their jobs how
come you don't care they're not american
citizens what are we talking about here
okay adam you sound like a conservative
this guy flip-flops more than a guy on a
vacation so
um it's just absurd it's just absurd and
sometimes you know
to my fellow democrats out there
sometimes you need some tough love
just like you know if someone's a family
member they need some tough love
this is freaking absurd how does someone
even justify this to to the aocs out
there to de blasio's out there whoever
the hell is running the show
like listen to the ridiculous the 1974
exodus of what happened with fortune 500
companies
like listen you realize you have
documentation to know what happened in
the 1970s when a massive exodus took
place
how do you not see trends in new york
how do you not see it how do you not see
that that
is taking place rewarding people for
doing nothing is one of the stupidest
things you can possibly do as a
government
and it is hurting businesses huge like
in california i'll give you an example
you go to restaurants that are finally
able to open again you know what their
biggest problem is
wait staff support staff they can't find
people because they cannot rehire the
people that used to work there
because they're making more money on
unemployment it doesn't make sense for
them to go back to work
so good restaurants then have to go to a
shrinking pool to try to find
qualified applicants that can handle
that they have to retrain them
they have to pay first they have to find
people that probably don't even have
experience as waiters and you see that
difference
you talk to restaurant owners it's a
huge huge problem this is just
so it's so stupid it almost makes you
wonder why democrats didn't think of it
sooner
right it's almost like a story you would
see in the onion and you're like oh okay
hilarious yeah exactly but it's not
fifteen scary stuff buddy fifteen
thousand dollars and it's
normal and it's untaxed too right i mean
they won't even imagine that
you know what like some people gonna be
like take away my green card give me the
money i'll be in
i'll be illegal i feel like they're
gonna they're gonna justify that by
saying with payments
up to fifteen thousand dollars meaning
they might not get the whole thing they
might qualify for a thousand dollars
aoc is celebrating right now you'll see
sitting there saying we are making new
york
more progressive be aoc for a second you
know flip the script you're aoc
yep why does this make sense why does
this make sense
some of the things that you said is you
like to to research the other side
just to kind of get started socialistic
philosophy
okay this is this is all we're going to
take care of you this is
what comes after this is when you take
care of undocumented immigrants
next comes if they live here and they
pay taxes they ought to be able to vote
as well
i mean you're leading to the direction
of wanting to allow undocumented
uh immigrants to be able to vote and
once that happens
forget about the anybody winning on the
right if that takes yeah but then
nobody's winning on the right in new
york anyway so
why is that such i don't know i think i
think we're too quick to
think that america is going to be the
greatest country in the world forever
like this money is going to be here
forever and we can spend it because
money is going to be here forever
you listen you are not rich forever you
know how people retire
and they're sitting down the money and
they're like oh you know i got my
retirement a million dollars
how are you 65. dude you're going to
live to 90. yeah
a million dollars at 65. 25. no no you
25 years say you get three percent
interest on your million dollars that's
30 000
say social security sends you another 20
grand that's 50 000
you you're gonna be able to afford that
for the next 25 years and your
lifestyle's been 150
no you need four or five million dollars
so people
think money supply and success lasts
forever it doesn't
new york is getting cocky new york is
getting arrogant
new york is thinking nobody will leave
them because it's new york city the
financial capital
of the world they forget that many other
financial capitals of the world
lost their reputation due to exact kind
of policies
that new york is doing they got to be
reading what's going on in the news they
got to be saying
what's going on they're already leaving
that sound like well maybe we'll leave
already left how do you how do you
reason with unreasonable human beings
but cuomo is the type of person that
seems reasonable yeah but
the only thing cuomo is thinking about
right now is to make sure he doesn't get
impeached what do you think he's almost
thinking about are you serious
cuomo wakes up every day with somebody
new coming out and saying he kissed me
on the cheek he did this he did that
every day he's got a different story
coming out i haven't heard many stories
in the last few weeks well
maybe they're happy because this passed
maybe that's why you kind of got
silenced
by the the people around him say the
exact same thing that he's only
governing to save himself
i mean that's it that's his main
motivation most of the time anyway
especially now you're not more powerful
than
the the tribe of democrats and everybody
on the socialist side you are not more
powerful than them you just are not it's
that's
it's that's straight up you think you
are you're not no matter how many lives
you did
everybody loved you cuomo no it's not
how this thing works so if you enjoyed
this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye